nina was wirst du heute machen
am nachmittag zu mir kommen
möchtest du am 8
zu mir kommen
wir können zusammen mein neues video
game spielen
ich kann heute leide nicht
werde am abend dann ein konzert gehen
ich werde am abend dann ein konzert
gehen
kennst du die band am bein
kennst du die bänder am bein
ja ich kenne sie die machen gute
rockmusik
genau ich freue mich schon auf das
konzert
am nachmittag werde ich beim friseur
meine haare schneiden lassen
danach werde ich mich umziehen und
schminken
ich werde
schwarz zum konzert gehen
in schwarz zum konzert gehen
vielleicht morgen wirst du morgen zu mir
kommen
morgen werden wir mit meiner familie
einen ausflug machen
wir werden uns mehr fahren
einem zeltplatz übernachten
wir werden erst am
tag zurück kommen
wir werden erst am montag zurück kommen
ich werde am wochenende keine zeit haben
ich werde am wochenende keine
zeit haben
wie sieht es nächste woche aus
o
nächste woche wird schwierig sein
die woche wird schwierig sein
ich werde nächste woche viel los haben
am montag werde ich für
in englisch test lernen müssen
am montag werde ich für den englisch
test lernen müssen
ich werde zuhause
einen
lernen
meine noten müssen besser werden sonst
werde ich das semester nicht bestehen
am dienstagnachmittag
termin beim zahnarzt
am dienstag nach
ich einen termin beim zahnarzt
wird mir einen zahn ziehen
er wird mir einen zahn
ziehen
wahrscheinlich werde ich mich danach
nicht gut fühlen
mittwochs
immer fußballtraining
mittwochs habe ich immer fußballtraining
am nächsten sonntag werden wir ein
wichtiges spiel haben wir werden hart
trainieren
am nächsten sonntag werden wir ein
wichtiges spiel haben wir werden hart
trainieren
am donnerstag werde ich mit meinen
eltern einkaufen
am donnerstag
werde ich mit meinen eltern einkaufen
meine schwester wieder eine
geburtstagsparty machen
meine schwester wird eine
erinnerst du dich
ja klar sie wird zwölf jahre alt oder
genau kommst du zur party
ja natürlich
lasst mich wissen ob ich euch irgendwie
helfen kann
gerne ich weiß gerade nicht was du mir
helfen kannst
ich weiß gerade in
nicht was du mir helfen kannst
aber mir fällt sicher noch etwas ein
so werdet ihr die party machen
sie wird im garten sein
und was ist wenn es regnen wird
dann müssen wir die partie
die im haus machen
dann müssen wir die party im haus machen
das wird nicht so lustig wie draußen
sein
aber der wetterbericht sieht gut aus die
sonne wird scheinen
wie viele personen werden zur party
kommen
[Musik]
ich glaube es werden circa 20 personen
kommen
wir werden viele spiele machen
mein vater
einen clown engagieren
mein vater wird einen clown engagieren
[Musik]
einen klar wirklich passiert lustig
werden
einen klar wirklich das wird lustig
was wirst du für ein geschenk kaufen
ich weiß es noch nicht
ich glaube ich werde ihr eine puppe
kaufen
eine puppe deine schwester ist zu alt
für eine puppe
was wirst du ihr schenken
das wird eine überraschung
was soll ich ihr schenken
sie ist deine schwester weißt du nicht
was sie sich wünscht
wofür interessieren sich mädchen in
diesem alter
ich weiß es nicht
wofür interessieren sich mädchen in
diesem alter
ich weiß es nicht
ich glaube dass sie sich über einen
gutschein freuen würde
dann wird sie selber aussuchen können
was sie sich wünscht
[Musik]
dann wird sie selber aussuchen können
was sie sich wünscht
das ist am einfachsten
wer wird den kuchen machen
meine mutter
ich glaube sie wird einen
schokoladenkuchen backen
so
ich wünsche sie einen schönen nachmittag
ich die auch bis nächsten samstag
ich die auch bis nächsten samstag hat
dir das video gefallen abonniere unseren
kanal möchtest du noch weitere videos
sehen dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video